boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm so
pumped to be talking about the golden
codes we have sandy Hart joining us on
the show thank you so much for having me
so so so honored to be here for this
yeah honor to have you as a guest thank
you
you've been transforming the
consciousness of so many humans
including myself that have been
attending your events for those who
don't know Sandy's background she's the
founder of golden codes which is a
multi-dimensional healing and ascension
technology you find the link in the bio
the golden codes dot love as well as
your Instagram profile sandy what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world
well okay do you want my honest answer
do you want the public answer like which
way are we gonna go just raw unfiltered
answer possible okay okay okay all right
all right right I'm sorry so just just
have to make sure okay so well there's a
few different timelines that can be
playing out because there is no definite
timeline that is for sure no matter what
prophecy that has been prophesized
depending on collective consciousness
karma that is still playing out and
still being decided to this day of what
is going to be happening what is
happening right now and just trajectory
what it looks like is that the earth is
splitting into two dimensions the new
earth and the old earth this is
something a lot of the new and now
majors are constantly acting about yes
it's actually true so the new earth is
it's a higher frequency
it's the 5d and up frequency it's the
love frequency it's the oneness
frequency it's what all the star beings
under the law of one are coming here to
help raise right and the other side of
that equation is the old patriotical
energies a lot of the Dark Age
frequencies that are still playing
themselves out there's a lot of higher
powers that be from very advanced star
systems that are keeping it that way
because it is an energy source for them
so what is going to happen well there's
going to be and is right now there's a
lot of people waking up really fast
there's a lot of abilities that are just
coming online there's a lot more
ayahuasca ceremonies San Pedro
ceremonies paleo peyote ceremonies and
fungi ceremonies and a lot of psychic
abilities are turning on why because
there are more lighthouses lightworkers
needed to be
to raise the vibration frequency for
this new earth to be a larger station so
for instance if if my station my radio
station frequency is something really
beautiful and high the more viewers that
I have subscribing to that frequency the
higher the frequency of the planet
becomes so that's the whole purpose of
populating positive frequency and it's
the same for the other frequencies
they're trying to populate their
frequency to attain a certain result
rather it's control and it's really
controlled and and to have it's from
fear and then there's love and then
there's surrender and connection and
community so there's these different
radio station frequencies that
everyone's subscribing to and so a lot
of people are choosing different things
to subscribe to so what happens is that
there's going to be a lot of shifts on
this planet there's gonna be a lot of
interesting the earth is gonna start
shaking off a lot of her flees let's
just say that and I'm not saying humans
are fleas but that's kind of it happens
that way like Oh a little earthquake
oops a little forest fire every year
well yeah
super easy Oh a supervolcano possibly
I'm not I'm not an apocalyptic necessary
I don't really jump into apocalyptic
stories that much but there will be some
things shaking and moving and those who
decide to live through their heart and
not live in fear and those who are
living in community and in through
selfless service they will step into
that higher frequency of vibration and
it is my belief that they'll be looked
out looked out after and they're gonna
live in harmony and peace within and
that earth the new earth is something
that happens inside of us it's not a
destination that frequency and vibration
that
that dimension is within and same for
the others and the and the more that
amplifies out that changes our outer
reality as well so that 3d reality that
were so trapped by and constricted by is
matching what our inner reality is so
yeah alright so many things from there
let's start with how in this long deep
time perspective of the evolution of the
planet yeah that there have always been
humans that have been that we've always
been we've always been coming through
from source through humans to play yes
all different types of from all
different places have been coming
through to play and that there's been
some sort of a goodness and malevolence
kind of at play and each have a tuning
fork
yeah and subscription models exactly
okay and now compared to previous times
there are eight billion collectively at
the same time which is like it's like a
peak point in terms of population hasn't
been this high but it's growing down and
then there's also the democratization of
exponential technologies that are making
it easier for malevolent actors or even
for creative people to empower
themselves so okay so then we have to
win this wisdom race of this of the good
and bad with the democratized
exponential technologies and so there's
there's more and more coming to play to
ensure that that that future debt
trajectory scape that you Illustrated
has all of the possibilities yeah and
then we are every moment the collective
consciousness is collapsing which
direction that we want to move so it's
not like guaranteed that like the Dow is
like for sure gonna end up here there's
no guarantee there is no guarantee
there's a lot you know the way to read
timelines and make predictions
is based off of the weather energetic
weather they're like well based off with
ejector is this and the past however
many things that have happened in the
past this is their trajectory and it is
a possible timeline maybe it's a very
strong one but we all have free will and
their share shared realities and then
there's your own reality so that's a lot
so you can't make a real prediction it
doesn't mean that someone who predicts
something can't be right you know that
doesn't mean that you know some people
are really good at winning that game do
you feel like you're in constant
communication with the higher self
that's channeling through your body and
making the moves in the it's the only
way yes the only way what do you how do
you envision that spirit how do you
communicate with that spirit that you're
it's embodied it's embodied yeah for
before it wasn't as much embodied and
that was something that took a lot of
cultivation and that took a lot of
clearing all sorts of old programs and
storylines and timelines that held my
human limitations in place and all of my
core wounds that were just all tied up
in that and you can't be a Clear Channel
when you have core wounds so deeply
woven in you because that is for
instance if you're if you're a crystal
and you're like hi I'm a channel and
then you're still having abandonment and
you have still this and this and this
and then you have God channeling through
you your higher self your cancel or your
angels or whatever it is that you work
with then that is channeling through you
with the filters of abandonment
attachment worthiness whatever it is
lack so that will always show up and the
more and more you clear all your
timelines that hold all those
contractions and distortions in place
the more clear you can be of a channel
and so I've done so much of that I'm not
saying I'm not ascended I'm not
enlightened or anything like that I'm on
my path and I've done a lot of work to
the point where
my channel is really doing beautifully
yes okay so there's a couple things I'm
gonna get right to that there is this
the the we work most clearly when we've
dealt with all the things that are in a
sense blocking our our channel that we
and in the subscriptions that we take
from birth have a deep root in our both
our subconscious programming as well as
our you know we we were talking about
this example I really like this example
about how you can then you can almost
hear music that doesn't serve you
anymore playing and that you just you
just no longer subscribe to it so you've
canceled that subscription and then you
maybe listen to music that elevates you
more that gets you closer to thanking
all that is opening your heart that type
of stuff and so I want you you have an
insane journey so tell us about how you
worked about your journey and how you
worked on clearing the things you needed
yeah unsubscribed yeah scribe to the new
things that have given you the golden
codes oh absolutely
okay so I came from New York I I had a
big party background I had maybe like
had 30 different careers I was a
professional chef I was a professional
makeup artist professional jewelry
designer professional singer and then I
was a did it did it you know like I
tried all the things that would do the
shoe didn't really fit as deeply to my
heart as I would have loved so I was in
a lot of searching mode and I was a
makeup artist at the time and I was a
socialite friends with every demographic
of humanity you could ever imagine
anywhere from the punks to the hi-hi
celebrities to the people in the street
all black clubs all raver clubs oh you
know just everything hard rock to reggae
scenes like I was just like a mutt of
frequency I just was into all of it and
I was studying them and I was looking
for something some type of connection
and I dabbled in a lot of cocaine I
dabbled in a lot of drinking and maybe
some other some other so-called medicine
as well and one day I just woke up and
decided to go raw foodist like
completely raw food live food and I got
inspired by a girl friend of mine she
had an amazing story and how pure and
clean you could be and I was like yeah I
want well I want whatever she's doing
her eyes are sparkling her hair is
flowing everything was just this
beautiful iridescent glow that she had
to her aura this is before I could even
read auras of any kind right so I'm just
like I don't know it's so obvious so
overnight I let go all of the toxic
stuff in my life anywhere from the
clothes to the shoes to the makeup to
everything my New York apartment moved
to San Francisco starting seeing flying
saucers started doing ayahuasca
ceremonies started trapped traveling
with David Wolfe and actually lived with
him for a couple years - and on tour and
being part of that community was so
beautiful and so learned so much in my
early 20s and I learned a lot and so
things started turning on around that
time because I also met this amazing
healer his name was Howard wills and he
was one of those he's one of those
people that walk in a room and heals
like I don't know a few hundred people
with snapping his fingers and then
people with cancer are gone and in all
sorts of like guy comas gone just all
sorts of diseases just vanish and he
could also make your armpits smell like
roses he did that to me even on the
phone once it was really ride so you
could see that like I was like wow that
is so cool like miracles that's where
it's at so I got really inspired and I
got I got to know him really well and
and then I got to know other healers and
I was really really curious and I
started adapting a lot of the work
started reading their prayers started
trying them and I noticed that whatever
was happening God was flowing through me
and there was something in there for me
I did not know at all the path that I
was going to be on to this day but so
after going through a few different
lifetimes from then I've been really
building an amazing rolodex of different
shamanic healers multi-dimensional
avatars and celestial priestesses and so
on so forth pretty much healers and
psychics right so I got all these
healers and psychics I'm pulling out
core wounds I'm getting rid of my mommy
issues once they're cleared my mommy
issues I had so much money come in my
life that was like my abundance block
and then there's the sensuality block
and then there's my daddy issues and
there's this past life issue from this
thing all the things that I used to just
like freak out about and I was to have
anxiety I used to have to pop pills just
to stay calm I had a lot of emotional it
my mom you know my mom she was pretty
troubled growing up as well so I just I
was around that a lot so it was very
flustered and I cleaned that up just by
clearing my past lifetimes and my inner
chat and my child wounding so when that
was cleaned up I was like wow this stuff
really works and then I got into even
more trauma especially a wrong
relationship and there were some things
that were happening to me and the thing
is when I decided that things were
happening for me when you take full
responsibility for everything that
happens to you meaning for you as God
moves through you then you can create
your reality and that is what lit
everything up everything everything
everything and so what happens is I
started clearing those wounds and when
those disappeared it felt like trillions
of daggers got lifted off of my chest
worlds and worlds of pain of old stories
martim templates a wounding of
worthiness and a bent abandonment and
betrayal and to see and just like all
these programs it's not even the feeling
of it
the attracting the same story over and
over and over again people would keep
getting cheated on people who keep
getting raped people who
keep getting their stuff stolen people
who can't find the way to make abundance
that comes from old past lifetimes or
this one and there is a loop there and
there's a there's a wound there that
needs to be pulled out from the root and
so when I did that all my ability
started turning on not all of them
because there's countless amount you
know we have like tons of abilities of
just waiting to like flood through
everyone but anyway a ton of them turned
on and when it was on it was on so this
work it's not like it's it's not like oh
yeah this gold encodes is something that
I've been curating for so so many years
I was like no when I actually took full
responsibility for all of my energy all
of it came on and it was been waiting to
turn back on and all these codes are
rightfully all of ours in different ways
different organic signatures yeah yeah
so we all have an endogenous beautiful
creative expression to gift the world
but we have to do these processes of
clearing in order for that to express
itself most fully and you had to do the
first like bifurcating moment was the
raw food yeah and so that was one and
then you you altered your trajectory
more towards your full expression of
your North Stars potential and then you
had another one with going into healing
prep modalities yes learning from
different sources building this rolodex
and then you kept going towards it with
the clearings and clearings of all sorts
so many of us have it may even be all of
us come in with some sort of things to
clear those are our biggest treasures on
the other side of the things that
exactly behind every trigger behind
every distortion behind every core wound
is a treasure and it's a superpower as
well the thing that you just don't even
want to face on the other side is
something that you're amazing at that's
why there's so many amazing
did healers why there are so many
amazing doctors like how many
neurosurgeons or her physical
practitioners you know became that
because that's what their issue was how
many sex therapists in Tantra healers
became Tantra healers because they had
sexual trauma so behind a wound is a
treasure and so it's good to go into our
wounds and what's the flip side of that
it's your magical essence just waiting
to be found and golden codes helps bring
first clear up the stuff and then making
room for your essence to grow for your
magical power everyone has magical
powers and they're all just kind of
hidden under the rough a little bit yes
so then that's that's it these gems that
are in the rough that have they're
almost there almost they almost have
kind of like dust slash char slash stuff
caked on to the gems when they're born
and then there's this process of needing
to needing to chip away at the dust and
clean off the tar and whatnot and then
that's actually what I'm really excited
to talk to Joyce about - as I am this
process of you are that North Star
that's embedded in that gem and to like
to dust off clean all the stuff up and
then hold it up in the sunlight for it
to fully express itself to the rest of
the world so golden codes unlocks that
kind of process of the dusting and
tarring so then it can shine so then how
did you pick the different modalities
that you are going to incorporate in
your gold and goats process and tell us
about what it's like people to attend
beautiful so as I was going through my
rolodex and constantly getting healings
by all these amazing healers I wish it
could be a lot faster I wish to give you
a little bit more quantum and I wish I
could have all in one don't you wish
that you could have your all in one
thing right it's just like wow it's just
like being a kid like I want to be a
unicorn and a sparkle kitty and Superman
and this and that and that and this and
I want to have my cake and eat it too
well that's my mentality minor child's
like great I want all of it now
I'm patient I have surrender always the
source but she's like I like let's get
it going there's got to be a better
solution there's got to be a way to
architect another modality that can
really help people through this a lot
more smoothly so you embarked on making
a compression algorithm for taking the
dust and the tar off of the gems faster
more effectively helping people shine
morphix exactly I noticed that usually
when I went to a healer like they can
likely clear one lifetime at a time or
two or three or four but not really like
some some really really good ones can do
a really high-level amount of them and
so I I was like well what if we could do
hundreds and I need to ask a question on
behalf of hopefully others as well is is
the idea that some literally if our
ancestors our parents and their parents
and not if they don't clean the dust and
tar off of their gems yeah and they
don't shine their gems most fully into
the world and if it still caked on when
they give birth to us yeah
then that is Kate those somewhat
similarities are kicked on to us and
that's this multi yeah is that what this
ancestral part ancestral lineage it's
also partly timelines as in like other
times I came in yeah it's so there's
there's ancestral wounding that's that's
going through your bloodline lineages
all right so that's ancestral wounding
and then there's also just past
lifetimes where you were of their people
you were still you your essence but you
might have been a girl you might have
been a Geisha you might have been
someone in the Civil War you might have
been Prince Albert you know like you
were all these different beings playing
out all these different stories growing
collecting karma collecting karma and
that can and when you collect karma can
go good or yes so there's a negative and
a positive karmic bank account and so
when you are in when you were in
reaction when you are reacting you're
creating a lot more negative timeline
what does that mean negative timelines
negative meaning that bad meaning not
your most desirable meaning you're gonna
get a lot more lessons that can
intensify until you have to move through
it and that's why people have intense
car accidents that's why really intense
stuff happens to people because the
universe your mirror is trying to wake
you out of your loop that you can't see
past and that's why those lessons keep
getting harder and harder harder until
you wake up maybe you shouldn't be
dating that girl maybe that person is
bad for you so it's gonna get so bad to
the point of she betrays you or you get
in a really bad accident like things can
really really things can get really
really intense right or you have that
job you're supposed to leave that job
and that jobs not good for you it's not
good for your essence not good for your
soul you're gonna get a lesson one way
or another and we do it so if when you
don't pay attention we don't listen
we're gonna create that so going back to
the karmic story so how do you not
create negative karma by not being
neutral having a still mind and when you
are not in reaction you're creating and
most people are in reaction instead of
in creation mode and when you are in
full creation mode and stillness and
when you can will your reality without
attachment without attachment is it's
the key yeah you know and when you're
spelling from your heart you're creating
beautiful timelines for yourself you
know that means your your desires life
purpose maybe you have a beloved maybe
you want to be alone maybe you're a
world traveler or maybe you get to you
know we can do both out of it we can do
this kind of one of the points of
meditation is to be able to take that
pause in heavy in chaotic moments one
and and then act after that so yeah this
is where we're going to get into
we're gonna talk about trigger surfing
oh you undo this now okay let's do that
now and just one more thing just for
again for those that I want to share
this with we talk a lot about these
hundred billion or so humans that have
come and built this world that we live
in right and it's sometimes it's hard
because a lot of people think that
consciousness is an emergent property
from just this like physical rock and
it's not you know science is still
building up the tool sets to be able to
like poke at the hypothesis that we come
from source as spirit to make with the
body this expression and then we go back
and come back and so you know sometimes
yeah so I just wanted to say it because
you know these are still school thoughts
so sometimes people can come in once
sometimes people come in a hundred times
throughout the history of oh I mean so
many beings were so ancient thousands of
lifetime's thousands of Hamsun these are
like lessons like earth is like a school
and we're like learning the lesson of
what it's like to grow up without
parents or within low income or high
income and all these issues that come
with all of different birth places
around the world the issues okay yeah we
all cheat and we're all choosing that
like using these choosing them you know
it's like I'm choosing to have a twin
flame relationship a beloved partner
that's gonna poke at me in every single
way and trigger me in every single way
and that's going to help me grow yeah
and the only way for me to get to this
level as I need this kind of a
partnership or I need that kind of a mom
that's not showing up for me or I need
this type of a limitation or I need to
be in jail for 20 years to learn
compassion and patience damn whoa yeah
you know and there's beings that are
coming in just to learn what it's like
to be dark and come some or just to be
light but at the same time their souls
get stuck in a karmic wheel too so they
also have free will so it's it's more
complex than I'm just gonna play a role
and everyone gets it like when everyone
leaves they just kind of get away with
it there's a it's a little bit deeper
than that
so okay yes okay so now I'm trigger
surfing and then we'll do the golden
code sex okay yes yes yes that's it you
mentioned this with the twin flame like
this soulmate style thinking that you're
kind of like if you if you identify what
someone's if you can really work with
someone you can like identify what
triggers are and help poke in a sense at
them too like if the other person can
meditate as their triggers are being
poked and they can like level themselves
off like it's harder than it looks and
harder than it's like literally I could
probably write a curriculum right now
and I'd probably still fail I'm doing
pretty good but like I'm just saying
like especially when it comes to twin
flames I don't think anything can poke
you more than the twin flame that's why
they're called flames and in this
context it can be non non-sexual as well
this can be oh yeah partnerships in
endeavors of course I'm like you can
work together for months or years or
whatever and then learn those lessons
that you need relationships is the
fastest way to grow it's we're all each
other's mirror and the only thing that
we're really being poked by ourselves
mmm
it's not the other person really poking
you I'm attracting my own poking I'm
attracting that there's something in me
that has a resonance that's like hi I'm
resin is 3 4 5 2 and that person's like
3 4 5 2 3 4 5 1 1 twice this [ __ ]
poking me it's like oh because there is
a resonance match 3 4 5 2 is a lesson
that you are here to learn yeah would
overcome that trigger to level your
character up past it's a video game
this whole ascension thing is a video
game that's what we're here you know to
do where we started a base level started
we're at 3d trying to pierce up right
we're trying to pierce up out of our
constricted reality of our human
limitations that we think are real in
this holographic prism
we call it a prison but it's really a
presumable how do you surf the triggers
in them oh yes yes okay so trigger
surfing first how do you face something
that you know is gonna be really
difficult you know how do you know like
for instance let's say I wanted to go to
high school reunion and I have tons of
trauma and I've been bullied and my
ex-boyfriend who dumped me was there and
maybe I have you know I didn't look good
and maybe I slept with my teacher who
knows like whatever whatever the story
is I'm like no I don't want to go back
there I'm never going back and my inner
child's super freaked out she's just
like no I'm not going back I'm like okay
okay well okay so what's your inner
child's name Atlas atlas okay so let's
let's well let's let's ask Atlas to come
in right now okay hi Atlas okay listen I
know you had a really really really
intense upbringing and your high school
reunion is coming up in two weeks how do
you feel like about going so if you're a
master you would say I'm [ __ ] pop to
go to my reunion yeah yeah and but if
you're scared and wounded your inner
child's like I don't know like
contracted I'm like okay well let's
let's make a game out of this like you
ready like if we if you game if I
trigger surfing like if you're about to
surf those waters that you don't want to
dive back into because that wave once
overtook you you're gonna tell your
inner child yo get your surfboard let's
go surfing like let's go to the store
we're gonna get some surfing clothes
what's your favorite colors you start
like pimping out his gear you poop out
his little avatar you get him super
stoked to be like okay yep that kid Pope
he might he poked at you before but
guess who you are now look how beautiful
you are
like let's show how strong we are how
much we've learned I was like right yeah
the path might go here Michael like that
your feelings you might feel things
things are gonna come up and guess what
we're gonna move right through and
before you know it your inner child is
just like okay cool yeah
getting pumped to see you gamified
create some kind of custom game to be
able to go through the system before you
know it you're doing riding right
through right and right through if I
prepped myself like that just get
yourself pumped like all right we're
gonna gamify this we're gonna have fun
if we game a fly to everything it would
be so much more fun we can learn we can
move through but when everything is so
serious and it's just like a little bit
intimidating and intimidating is
something that like the inner child
feels and the inner child is in charge
of a lot of our decisions and a lot of
our follow throughs believe it or not my
inner child is actually in charge of all
of my magic I'm just the limo driver I
just drive this lady around this little
young girl that she just makes all the
magic happen okay so imagine the trigger
comes at you boom ouch oh that doesn't
feel good that's bringing me anxiety I
have a lot of fight-or-flight coming up
I'm starting to sweat I'm starting to
get really angry I have this like energy
I just need to burn out and react okay
so remember what I said about karma you
were when you into reaction you can
create negative Karma
mm-hmm and when you are in neutrality
you create actually positive Tom limes
right okay so here's an exercise option
a imagine this like a little iPad like a
little holographic iPad it's like option
a react play victim let's have a hissy
fit you know whatever it is that you
would do it's like okay yeah I want to
pick that one because that's what I'm
really in resonance with right now it's
like okay cool have a little bit more
information click on that it's like what
happens if you click a Oh
creating negative timelines yeah I know
I don't I'm not really in resonance with
that okay what's option B sweep it under
the rug and pretend it didn't happen oh
no that's just suppressing it and that's
just gonna create other other issues so
you look under that and see you can see
the fall backs of that okay option C see
the beauty in the situations see how you
created your own reality see what a
master you are at creating this
beautiful or
stray ssin and you know what even if you
don't believe that in the moment because
you probably won't because you're still
in fight-or-flight and that energy is
still rushing through you it doesn't
matter click on it fake it till you make
it
click on it and stick with it just don't
react you're gonna have to and after you
click that don't make any more reactions
or anything like I'm actually gonna come
back to this later you breathe you walk
away from the situation you come back
later and see what you clicked on you
check it out and you'll be super proud
of yourself like hah I walked away from
something that could have really created
some negative timelines for myself and
I'm so happy I passed the test it was
not easy but I did it mmm and so that's
how you trigger surf and at first it's a
little bit inorganic a little bit
technical and after a while it just
becomes like first nature like your
metaphor of the little decision screen
appears and then you can view what the
different options and that's what I'm
sure will be talking to Joyce about a
bit as well
that that gamma fication of those
bifurcating moments in our trajectory
have like you said karmic effects
they've timeline effects always types of
things and to treat it more like a game
where we're choosing the option that is
most aligned with our North Star and our
creative expression is is huge ok so we
can do that for all these triggers all
these blocks for our gem we can do this
process you just demystify the charge so
if you're feeling a charge and you're
like man that guy but that guy
completely cut me off on the road and
you gave me the finger
and I just feel super like angry and
triggered and if you actually just sit
with yourself for a moment and feel the
root of the trigger is it really him or
her why am I so and what is the root of
this anger and once you've we were like
oh shoot you know what I just have this
anger I just actually have a lack of
patience or I don't like it when someone
house has the last word or I don't like
it when a B and C happens and I'm like
ok well that's my [ __ ] so that little
character appeared in the game to test
is like a test of faith whatever that
for you to learn
we're all doing that that simultaneously
for each other I'm the main character of
my own movie and you're helping me grow
and you're the main character of your
movies vice versa yeah yeah eight
billion of us in is nature is that play
to that like animals and we're all of
God's creation there's all God's
creation is is at play doing the these
like little tests and whatnot for each
other
okay that's the geometry that that
that's how I see what God is God is that
architecture that is constantly all
playing itself out and the one that's
how I that's how we see that we're all
connected in one in that way yes okay
now taking the different modalities of
that you learned in this rolodex and
applying it to a compression algorithm
of golden coats to let that shine I
didn't necessarily take a bunch of other
people's modalities I took a lot of
reference points reference points
reference points I pretty much the world
has been my muse and colors and textures
and even watching the you know the way
hospitals work and everything just
movies and stories all of these are
references of information of how things
work in this world right so in the 3d so
for instance if I if I'm gonna do a
healing on you and you were really sick
I would probably I would tell Saint
Germain to cook you up something and
make you something like great well
where's the thing I'm like no I just you
just made it for you and I gave you an
IV of light and you're good well that's
a reference point from surgery or that's
a reference point from getting a light
blood transfusion I could say it in it
made millions of ways it's just a
creative way of asking source and all
the different aspects of source to give
me what we need for this situation be
taken care of okay
so then there's a process of you like
synthesizing these different assets yes
and just some sort of a beautiful
creation that
involves lights and scents and song and
musical instruments and deep meditative
practices that just unlock so much
beauty for me and for all the others
that were participating and you do these
so frequently so yeah so yeah with the
golden codes is as he said a healing and
ascension technology it is broken up
into three parts initially the first is
the cosmic cleanup which is going
through all of your core wounds all of
the unnecessary frequencies and energies
that are in your field holding your
human limitations in place human
limitations meaning your human
limitations your constrictions your lack
you're not enough nests
you're at the separation the sadness the
tension all of that the what we think is
real but it's not enough all of that
that can all be shifted recoded recode
your reality and activate your gold
print is the point is to recode the
reality that has been coded by some
energies and forces that I won't mention
at this time to keep us asleep and the
purpose is for all of us to wake up or
for those who are ready even more
importantly so what does that mean when
we're asleep well we have so many
programs in us that have kept our DNA
dormant that have kept our consciousness
filled with a lot of undefined
programming on divine programming for
movies and TVs and music shows and
you're not enough from your parents or
your schoolteacher and whatever the
government just life human stuff right
the Dark Ages goes on and on and on all
of that to keep separation constantly
when humans are separated then they're
in fear and when they're in fear you can
monetize off of that so that's an energy
source so how do what do we do with that
what do we do when that is the greatest
threat to heat to life right now is you
free it on program it and
bring in the true codes that everyone
does have we all have those high wisdom
codes we all a lot of us are such
amazing star beings that are
multi-dimensional avatars with like you
don't have to be a healer to be an
avatar you don't have to be a healer to
have super powers like everyone can have
that everyone is that special and I'm
here to remind all of us of that nope
and not just remind but also get to it
yeah so so the cosmic cleanup is it goes
into the Akashic records and the halls
of Amenti and my ass make records hidden
portals and pocket realms and all sorts
of template so it goes into all of your
libraries in for information that hold
all of your footprints from past future
and present lifetimes that holds all of
those human limitations a place swept
and clean of what is allowed to be
removed at the time according to the the
karmic law you know because you know
what can be removed today can't be
removed tomorrow the did to do so after
that then we're moving into the second
phase the second phase is the
multi-dimensional filtration system that
is protecting your field from other
frequencies that shouldn't be looking
into your field okay that's gonna be
protecting you
on some level because I can't say any
hundred percents on the show from 5g
frequencies from radioactive frequencies
and from energies that been taken out
for them to come back in so you just
it's a protection shield initially it's
just very very multifaceted so after
that has been done then we're going to
the light body activations this is the
fun part the golden codes right so the
Kythera grid the golden ascending a spa
the ascending spiral frequencies to
ascend or consciousness ascend or DNA
all of that comes in so it's a lot of
new geometries that come in its the
geometries of the Golden Age the Golden
Age that is amongst us and those are
geometries that our dispensation right
now right now to the planet waking up
our plant life is going to be changing
our water is going to be changing the
DNA of
everything's upgrading on this planet
has the ability to that and we have to
to be able to be in resonance with the
frequency that their earth is actually
rising to which is why there's all a lot
of intensity happening at the same time
there's gonna be a lot of shake off too
so it's good to get with the program now
after that then we're gonna get into
some brain rewiring negative
subconscious reprogramming with there's
so much to do there and then you're
making room for the Bodhisattva Klein
dispensations higher mind dispensations
after the higher mind dispensations and
brain infusions and doing energetic
ozone treatments into your body
energetically only speaking then we're
going into a triple heart activation
we're doing full chakra activation
expansion harmonization revitalization
we're doing regretting we're doing many
angelic dispensations so on so forth a
the the list is very very long it's
pretty much like a book book long and it
keeps growing so how do we do golden
codes that like how why how can we do it
in such a short period of time because
there are libraries of information all
put into one quote why quantum magic
yeah you know it's all it's all in
tension there's so much light and so
much information and information is in
these different geometries of light and
these geometries of light hold a certain
imprint of what how it can affect us and
change the bio circuitry of our system
to be able to operate in a different way
and hold more light and have more
resonance with other things that have
resonance and see how everything
connects in that way and so then you
know we're grounding you down to the
crystal core the earth and connecting
you deeper your guides doing third eye
activations and heart you know different
activations depending on what you need
so we do we meaning I there's also
besides that I have a team of Angelics
my beloved joyous also assists with
golden code since
beautiful manner and we do all the
events together and he's just been such
a joy to work with and yeah just it's
it's been the events have been
incredible that has been my greatest joy
I love personal sessions I would say the
events is where I can actually I I speak
in light language and I sing in light
language and this is where I can also
play with other healers and other sound
technicians other sound healers that are
just have so much to bring and then I
can play with them someone else brings
some an element and then I have pretty
what would goal what makes Golden codes
so easy to show up at events is that I
have a script in this script no matter
what I have an hour along or I could do
a 30-minute or a 90-minute and so it's
so much easier to play with others and
people close their eyes they lie down
and I shut off their mind because you're
put under anesthesia energetically
speaking which is all just high
frequency a high frequency euphoric
state that you step into you feel just
held held and loved and fully taken care
of and no one purges no one goes through
any negative side effects of any kind
it's just like really really really
sweet and it's so much joy I find fine
just as much joy in this as I do and any
other playful activity or maybe the most
besides spinning tell my children so
yeah it's it's a lot there's a lot of
information I could probably sit here
for like hours and days years going on
and on and on there's so many different
fractal ways we can talk and break
things apart and look at it there's a
lot to cover so wherever you drive whoa
so the importance of activating people
faster and just taking all of the
different areas of study that you've
taken from that make the process so it's
not just like a
activation it's like I've learned a
ridiculous amount of information I've
incorporated it into novel ways that I'm
very aligned if I powers to do
yeah people can't just sign on and like
try to do a golden codes even if I gave
them the script and they're like okay
you do it now like it's something you
have to earn over time and it's not like
I had to I had to go through my
initiations to do that and what I would
love to offer those who do want to learn
about this type of healing this type of
next level quantum healing because is
there's a lot of quantum healers and
they're all really really amazing but
what I want to teach people is how to
create their own modalities is to be
their own modality and be their own guru
and their own mentor so there's golden
codes that exist now there could be you
know like a light codes or an ascension
codes or whatever you want to call these
different modalities that people would
train themselves on helping awaken
others and activate others there's some
fundamental things that need to be taken
care of first
first is building their relationship
with sort with source and the spirit and
cleaning and purifying their vessels
it's a lot of purification I'm all about
purification and integrity so like one
thing about my work you'll know is that
I'm very thorough and I'm very clean and
I and I hold a very very sacred
container always and so I would take it
seriously if I took anyone under my wing
that was learning anything and making
sure that before they get at like no
one's allowed to get a new spider-man
suit until they freakin earned it
and that means me too I'm still earning
new stars all the time constantly yeah
and in different levels and I will
always be even source is growing every
day even they send in masters and all
the Angelics and all the star beings are
upgrading constantly and they're godly
getting initiated to new realms of
higher consciousness not just as humans
I love how you're explaining it in the
sense that like you you gotta earn your
accolades and your experience points and
your building skill sets up before being
able to like take on big in to do
something like this there's so much
still to unpack on just the subject
responsibility I want I want to give
people um a little bit of an idea on
like if you know you got one coming up
here in the Bay Area on Friday and
there's gonna be more that come up
around this is mostly United States or
if it goes around at this time at this
time and then what you know what then
what then would someone that is you know
either
coming into to experience this what
would you then say that like they can
help get what they need cleared in order
to help themselves to help activate
themselves that's that's pretty much if
that's what they're looking for yes
that's what I would say people come in
looking for different yes so what
happens is when a person comes into the
event we have quite a few different
facilitators there's other hands on
touch healers and people with tuning
forts and people doing singing bowls
everyone has like a different mastery
and I'm kind of like an Orchestrator and
and I interview everyone who comes in
and I ask them what they want to release
and what they want to call in I remember
doing that right so we'll focus on their
intentions and your intention will will
be focused on and a lot more than that
but it's just making sure that that has
its focus because we're gonna be working
on all the core wounds but making sure
that that one is also primarily like
that we're not going to miss that it's
really really important maybe you want
to call in so I mean there's been some
interesting we've had some amazing
events some people break out and orgasms
some people break out I mean we've had
ones were there was groups of people
having orgasms just simultaneously all
together and I was like that's really
interesting it's not like I touched them
or did anything to their lower chakras
to simulate that or maybe I did after
some people just like burst out and
laughter some people find their Higher
Self and remember their purpose some
people just really relax and they fall
asleep and then wake up and then all of
a sudden weeks later they're like okay
something's different those limitations
are not or I'm moving to another country
or I have to do this more I'm not this
person anymore
it's different for everyone yeah whoa
what a yeah diverse yeah a list of
different trajectories that people take
either yet during that's what you're
ready for words it's good that you come
you you do ask that that what is their
intent with what is their intent to both
eliminate and obtain yeah I want to make
sure everyone feels held and has that
special attention and we you know we we
have met different types of events that
have different frequencies and energies
and libations that we do provide and we
have also provide private sessions
afterwards first higher tiers if people
want to work through things even
one-on-one so I'll work for hours after
and have a special other sacred space
and we'll go deep and you know that's
like having two big sessions and one
night that's a lot shifting that's a lot
of timelines it's not a small it's not a
small session it's not it's a it's a big
deal for your field it's a big deal for
your field that's okay for those that
can't attend the golden codes on Friday
or maybe a nearby event to them in the
future they're around the world wherever
whatever wherever they're watching from
listening from what is a core principle
that people could embody we talked about
so many things of how to take some dust
or tar off of this beautiful gem and how
to have it shine brightly and express
itself creatively what could be maybe a
couple core principles that you could
advise people on
principles when they walk away from the
event I'm suppose for if they're unable
to attend a golden codes event because
they're around the world or what it why
not what can they do if they can't get
golden codes yeah what can they do to
better kind of yet it's a yeah if they
can't give little codes but if they also
just if they maybe feel things that
you're talking about yeah and they've
maybe heard some of the recommendations
like that pause like that optionality
yeah that is the most important thing
because golden codes is not the only way
to ascend your consciousness it is a
really it's a golden elevator is what it
is I mean there's tons of ways to ascend
your consciousness through there Pete
there's Yogi's through their breath work
there's people who just meditate a lot
and all of a sudden if when you stop
thinking negative thoughts for a very
very long time you're in neutrality
right when you're on neutrality a lot of
those negative timelines melt away a lot
of people burn off negative timelines
through having intense experiences and
initiations there's all sorts of things
ways to do that and they all might take
different levels of time now yes that
trigger surfing what it comes down to is
having a neutral still mind and being in
your heart is the number one thing it's
really really simple is treating
everyone with the highest level of
respect having a high level of
discernment but not judgement judgement
creates negative timelines as well and
there's a fine level of fine line
especially in in a lot of communities
that I'm aware of that don't really know
the difference between judgment and
discernment but it's easy to cross that
line so it's easy to create negative
timelines based on where you're at as
well so it's really important meditation
having a still mind game of fine your
experience every single day being able
to catch when you're about to get fiery
or you're about to explode you're about
to get on the phone with your mom and
your mom's gonna ask you that stupid
question she honestly asks you and that
triggers you okay
that is your playing ground that's your
videogame playing ground right now
and that every test you're like oh shoot
I'm being tested every test is an
opportunity yeah and that opportunity is
to get through that other level of this
video game so that the only way you're
gonna ascend is by passing those tests
yeah pass tests collect alkaloids skill
points yeah hold up you experienced yes
and they're gonna have friends and peers
that can help you along your way just
like when you're playing a video game
you're gonna have a little Yoshi you're
gonna have a little ol you have a what's
his name Luigi you're gonna have little
sidekicks and guides and beings on this
dimension and others depending on who
you are and how you roll that are gonna
be here you're gonna have tools in your
tool belt maybe you're a tapper maybe
you need to do yoga maybe you're a
tantric master maybe you need to like
punch a punching bag you know like
everyone's got like a different flavor
on how to work through energy but as
long as you can still the mind and not
go into reaction and see the higher
purpose in it and take responsibility
for everything that happens to you
you're on your own point damn
okay still mine take responsibility for
everything that happens to you see it
like a game that you leveling up it's
just the game is a tool you don't have
to see it as a game it's just it's a
recommendation recommendation it's a
recommendation to get all the aspects of
your consciousness on board to be able
to maneuver through triggers
yeah and ascend to your consciousness
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay I
think that was I was very solid results
and this is perfect especially for those
that are watching and/or listening that
are unable to of course I think that was
that was very solid Wow okay
also personal sessions are available
yeah personal sessions also I that's
that's big to reach out golden codes
that love for those that want the you
have personal sessions yeah based in
Southern California at the moment at the
moment so for those that are interested
in California especially can easily
access that mm-hmm so okay there is
there's something about what's happening
is it exactly where it's supposed to be
or did we venture off of the dow are we
on the exact course exactly right place
we're supposed to be collectively
consciously collectively consciously
we're all exactly where we're meant to
be and it's like moment to moment no
matter what past we've picked or what
future were picking we're all in our
path no matter what and both
individually but collectively to mmm
that every moment no matter where things
go it's exactly what everything is
perfect just as it should be things
perfect justice should be especially
with the all the malevolent forces that
are pressing right up against the
positive ones it's the most beautiful
artistic expression when it's just like
that it's just a reflection of yourself
and you know we're taking full
responsibility for all of it and it's
not easy to do that and that's why this
whole ascension thing is such a big deal
and why so many ascended masters and
grooves like Buddha for instance you
know how many initiations that brother
went through to be able to get to worry
like that was tough or people coming in
as fast as the lighthouses
yeah you're talking about like yourself
yeah that are doing these consciousness
ascensions are people coming in on the
other side just as fast to try and oh
yeah yeah what do you call those if
they're not like a lighthouse would you
know what are the ones on the other side
of their dark house vampires
it's just like an energy socket yes
basically they just suck the enter there
they're trying to take they're not
trying to share and give I mean I don't
go around use that word a lot it's not
like in my lingo a lot but it just came
to mind really said that it's just an
energy that wants to take soothe a
parasitical so like pantheism is is like
all is god that's you know pantheism
zoster yeah okay so is then there is
there is is there something beyond
source or is just all source
well that would defeat the purpose of it
being called source okay so it's all
source okay there's nothing beyond
sources all source no one can prove that
it would be and then and then from from
source yeah then there is these these
spirit to body entries on two different
rocks sources this game just playing out
right source is this beautiful
architecture game that's just playing
out and it once started off really
simple let's just like make it a really
simple storage one started off really
simple and there were a lot of energies
that were created with free wills and
their own choices and some storylines
started playing out and there was
different aspects and different
personalities and tones and colors and
everything's just playing itself out and
you know does God intervene yes
depending on your will okay there's this
so much even to say from there but do we
do we also go play on other rocks
orbiting stars in this galaxy and other
galaxies and other universe we know is
is this specific iteration of a rock
called Earth orbiting a star
yeah our son yeah is this the most
important one or just one of many it is
um it's a really popular one it's um
it's a really sought out a sought out
after one there are other planets that
have beings that look like us earth
particularly I know it's intense it
feels like a nuthouse is the one that
has a really long VIP list and there's a
lot of beings that are trying to
incarnate and you're trying to come here
I know we're like are you kidding just
just go to blade ease like yeah you
don't want to come here right but it's
it's it's a planet that a lot of beings
are growing so much exponentially
there's so much rich richness in that
there's the treasure in that it's hard
for us to even wrap our minds around
because we're like okay man like this
it's kind of okay so the nuthouse is the
reason why there's a long VIP list
because people want to come and level up
because there's a big challenge is here
to overcome it yeah and support systems
there's a lot of beings that are that
are have special coding and they're
coding our to be a mission to help the
planet word so it's like there's
multiple stories playing out all at the
same time but yes you're right to what
you said whoa it's so cool to think
about just where to incarnate and where
what experiences to have and and and
some beings are almost done in card
reincarnating here some are like okay
I've done my work this is my last this
last time and a lot of beings right now
I'm a big trajectory for the future of
this civilization that needs a lot of
help it needs a lot of help and there's
a lot of beings are like I'm gonna do it
from up there I'm gonna I'm gonna work
from a home now I don't need to come to
the off and say you work from home when
you go oh like actually work from home
yeah how do you how after you've come
and done one interval with your heart on
this rock do you can you go back or
several intervals over how do you
finally go home there's no cycle how do
how do you work from home you know how
do you do that uh okay how do I work
from home from other planets or how do I
work from a home as a as a
multi-dimensional healer how do you work
from home source well because your your
guiding other beings here just like
let's say I have Mike yeah for instance
if I'm if I'm being guided by Arcturians
and they're chillin on Arcturus having
Arcturian mai-tais sippin on the beach
or like everything's purple and gloomy
just like your shirt right I'm chilling
in that I'll not planet right now I'm
just like yeah what's up and then like I
get the ring you're like hey what up
Billy what's going on and Billy's like
meditating is like I'm getting in touch
with my Arcturian guides and then he's
like yeah what up yep yep of course yeah
I can remove those vampiric for you no
problems here awesome cool yeah I'll
talk to you Wednesday that's how you are
come home that suder's
so there's within all that is there are
a ridiculous amount of communications
yeah ring I mean there was a funny
example there's so many beings countless
that can be in many places at the same
time and there are home planets that
your it as a star seed you have a home
planet somewhere and those beings are
helping you out right now and there's
also other planets that you have planet
hopped around and you're connected with
them too and they're helping you as well
and as multi-dimensional being you can
be in multiple dimensions as one at once
and be multiple beings at once and they
can come in work through you work as you
to some people have walkins and walkins
or spirits that come through us and talk
through us and work through us which is
beautiful so whoa yeah we've had plenty
of stories now where people have shared
where it feels like that there was a
walk in that occurred and then some
trajectories went in different
directions
okay now what just quickly to us explain
what do you what does a star see it in a
home planet what is that yeah a star
seed
is when you come from these other stars
stars lineages their star lineages
there's different star systems that hold
these different codes and they're
different some come from different
universes in the summer from this one so
you have like the Pelagians you have the
Arcturians you have the lions you have
the the avians and then you have the
aqua fairy ins and then you have the
Andromeda and then you have the you know
you get the Christ Chilean star system
and it just goes on and on and on the
Syrians and they come from different
star systems and they all have their
different signature abilities and
they're all different aspects of source
they all have high high source codes
they're very very high frequencies some
are in the fortieth dimension and up and
some are on the eighth dimension some on
their 16th dimension depending on where
they're at and they all hold different
codes like for instance Arcturians are
really amazing with technologies and
Pelagians hold a lot of love codes and
they're very very affectionate and they
have a lot of their light body
transmissions are super super powerful
and they're also keep they hold the keys
to a lot of wisdom like a lot of wisdom
keepers and then their drawings are the
architects and the Aqua Farren's is the
water planet and all the water elemental
frequencies and very very very very high
frequencies and then like there's a
there's a star system where a lot of the
christ'
energies came from so a lot of the
christ' stick energies comes from the
crystal star systems which is actually
it's just galaxies it's a star system of
a few different planets and it's a lot
of that intelligence that lives within
there and there's also something called
the mother arc and the father arc where
the divine mother and the divine father
reside which is a whole nother subject
whoa and that's really deep the divine
mother is actually many different
divine mother's like working in a cosmos
of divine intelligence working on her
behalf constantly pertree birthing the
universe there's so many different
universes within universes but yeah
there's and then then you have the
angelic
realm the celestial realms I have so
many questions that we will be able to
unpack on another or next yeah
conversation together on this yeah well
I think we've just done super awesomely
unpacking who you are and like what you
represent golden codes I'm really proud
and you've you you've given me so many
new ways to like see the world and also
like conversationally wise like there's
just so many directions to take this
you're obviously extremely studied on
spirituality and synthesised I know some
things yeah but I'm not I wouldn't call
myself even like there's some people
that really really have studied and have
gone so deep book wise they're like oh
well I wanted to like 80000 workshops
and rates read so many books
I don't read I don't read books so I
kind of just was influenced by my
environments and I and I also Channel
and then I have my work checked just
like a scientist does yeah yet that
that's that's a critical component to is
that you have this feedback loop that
happens how do you know when you're
channeling that it's correct how do you
know when you're getting information
that is not just a bunch of mumbo-jumbo
or false light programs false light
program is when you're channeling a
being that is not what he or she or it
says it is and that can easily happen
when your channel is not clear and when
you have a lot of core wounding and
programs inside of you which is
extremely common actually the most
common thing ever and it's totally ok so
how do you know so something that I
practice is when I channel or something
comes through and I'm like wow this is
epic amazing feels really good awesome I
want to get it checked out why because
I'm responsible for a lot of lives
you're responsible for a lot of decision
making and if I don't check my work if I
don't check myself and I know better
then that's negative karmic
repercussions for me
and how do you get your checked is I
have other psychics and healers and
other people that are really amazing
world renowned at what they do I have
maybe a five - six - seven - eight
depending on what the situation is have
them all check and if they're all saying
yes then I'm gonna go with that yes
because that's citizens that's
statistics not only is just statistics
that's source showing me yes yes yes
because you're you're reading the
symbology you can read you don't have to
be that kind of a psychic to read
everything you can read life how the way
how everything shows up to you God is
constantly speaking to you and through
you through everything that happens to
you here's a sign here's a sign so if
I'm like God show me six signs that this
channel is accurate I'm gonna get that
sign and and and and when I get that
that's great so what happens if it's
half yes and half no that's a great
question
then don't act on it and constant and
research further and then I become debt
that becomes a project which was a
project that becomes a project I put
that in the project file so my
consciousness is like a desktop most of
ours we seem to think of it that way
so if I have something that comes up and
it's unresolved it's not fully clear
which happens quite often being a human
I'm like okay I'm putting that under
investigation so I'm what I do is I
create a lot of stillness around it and
all especially around for three months
I'll watch it and I'll play with it and
interact with it and see what comes up
and see what what within me what shadow
aspects within me are creating a lot of
distortion and also are there any
distortions in that and I'm starting to
see what adds up you're starting to see
what overcompensates and under
compensates so it's I read geometries
energetically I see and feel things on
how they show up constantly and so I'm
just keeping track I'm constantly
keeping track and then the answers show
up and then I get it checked
again later on and then the answer is
clean always always always always always
whoa it's a big responsibility it's a
lot of work it is yeah and it's
important to be patient to very patient
very patient and also it's so sometimes
it can be difficult to to tap into the
reading of something as something that
you know if you are being patient and
putting it away and then maybe it's
still like 50/50 and you're still
waiting you can be hard to read things
as are they pro are they against are
they neutral so yeah but sometimes I
know that it feels more clear with
intuition sometimes it feels a little
bit more foggy take it to be patient
let's wrap on two questions are we in a
simulation yes
explain more I'm not going to any more
explanations for season okay okay what
is the most beautiful thing in the world
my children my family my relationships
with my most precious precious precious
innocent sweet wild loving creatures
that you know I called home so my
beloved joyous angelina and Malachi that
bring me so much spark in every single
moment and I can't I can't even compare
that to any rainbow and any activation
or superhero power of any kind that is
it's just simple it's simple divine love
if you make so many likely people that
may not know that especially people that
are super focused on mimetics or
spreading ideas around the world they're
not so focused on genetics and like
procreation the likely making people
more interested in like why are so many
people say that the most beautiful thing
in the world is having children didn't
like and seeing the love and the you
have to experience it - really - no - no
no actually sorry I didn't mean to
create that limitation for you some
people actually know some people have
known for many lifetimes and if they
just know but if you don't know and you
experience it you will know but you know
what some people are not necessarily cut
out for that so it's not a one in this
yeah or they're having a tougher
situation maybe they're a single parent
and it's tougher for them or they're
maybe I having the best single parent
motherhood their hood experience
everyone's different but all I have to
say is that the experience of that is
something that you can't put into words
you can't and the experience of source
and being alive is something really
difficult to put into words it's just
life is such a miracle and what makes it
such a miracle is being fully present
with it yeah its presence is crew is is
actually what the miracle is otherwise
we're constantly analyzing it trying to
pick at it trying to do all this stuff
with it and no matter what life is
happening it's always gonna be evolving
and it's always gonna magic still
happening no matter what you do and try
to figure out with it but having full
presence as it's happening and embodying
that energy and building that
relationship with it in every single
moment and seeing the miracles in every
mundane moment mundane that's the
miracle yeah when boredom can become a
luxury you know it's everything just
like even just like walking down a
street that's not so fond or eating
imagine you were eating the same food
every day can you possibly make it
different experience every single time I
have I have to actually tried that for a
year I've tried that for a year like
literally had the same meal like every
single day when I was at became a raw
foodist and I kept eating the same thing
and it was an orgasm every time and
never tasted the same and I went into
this complete simplicity meditation and
I just kept finding new flavors and new
ways to make love with the experience
yeah which is another form of Tantra I'm
not necessarily a tantric master but I
think that's what that is and allowing
ways to make love with even the most
mundane aspects of reality absolutely
yeah Sandee we have so much more to talk
about around - I feel so damn
enlightened I appreciate so much you
come in Friday yeah we got you show a
nori - okay yeah yeah we're he's got a
Mama's bday but afterward we'll see if
he cannot join us I think so like Wow
huh okay thank you everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it would love
to hear our thoughts in the comments
below on this episode this is a
definitely episode to comment on and let
us know what you're thinking also do
check out the links in the Bible o -
golden code style of as well as Sandy's
Instagram profile and have more
conversations with your friends or
families co-workers people online Oh Bob
what we talked about in this episode
dust off that gem and have it shine so
beautifully in the world and do the
hacks and on the way to you treat life
like a game all these types of things
level up level up level up make it fun
shout out to Horry Shapiro for producing
thank you very much Laurie and also go
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in we'll see you soon